hello I'm Ray Dalio and I'm happy to be
here with Paul Volcker who is my
greatest hero and probably too many
people the greatest living American and
that's a big statement
I've watched Paul evolve since 1970 when
he was under secretary of the Treasury
of Monetary Affairs all the way through
the present and during those years he
had more effect on the world economy and
built up more credibility and has been
at the center of more economic
decision-making than any man alive in
his 91 years he's affected the world in
profound ways that we some of which are
very famous and some of which are just a
reflection of his credibility for
example when the issue the controversial
issue of the monies that Jews were lost
in the Holocaust went into Swiss banks
and that very delicate subject very
different from regular economics the man
that they chose to examine that question
was Paul Volcker Paul in many many
different occasions and at many
different times shaped many many
different issues so this is a man who
has extraordinary principles I've known
him to be the most principled person
that I know and also to been at the
center of most important economic
decision-making during those many many
years but for many decades and to see
things from the top this is a man with
great perspective and so I'm here today
to pull out the principles of from Paul
and to understand how he got those
principles so Paul to start off please
give me what you consider to be what
your most important principles well
first of all thank you for those very
generous comments and let me say I'm
glad to see you here at this point I've
been a little
the weather I hope I'm recovering but
you know it's a book I just wrote we've
got something to talk about you asked
one of my principles and the first thing
that comes to mind so I'm sure we'll get
to later is my first principle is
effective governance and I go back and
we can discuss this in more detail
Alexander Hamilton put it all in a
nutshell Alexander Hamilton is an old
Treasury guy he's a financial guy he
restored the credit of the United States
so he's a hero of mine he said the true
test of good government is his ability
to administer not the great policy we
can they carry out the policies
effectively and economically and good
government is not just high policy it's
making the Machine work day after day
efficiently faith of the American people
in our government today is really
distressing you have been polls taken
every year ask the same question and see
how the transgenders do you trust your
government to do the right thing most of
the time didn't sound the right thing
most of the time doesn't sound like a
lot of difficult to test you get maybe
20 percent to say yes just about the
Congress will be less than 20 percent
and it's no great secret
we're torn apart by ideological and
other differences now so we've got a
real challenge so when you ask my
principles my first principle is good
governance when you talk about
principles like a dad in the family and
we were not a family that spent money
easily
we like to economize and be sure how we
were spending money I'd like to think we
carry this over or I carry it over when
I have some responsibilities and
government to try to do it sufficiently
not only is accurately but as
efficiently as possible you know my
mentioned my father he took over a city
manager of this bankrupt town in 1930
and lasted for 20 years but he became
the principle figure in the town has no
question he was the best known and
fortunately highly respected but he was
a fanatic for disclosure he would do a
very detailed budget every year and
disputed it to everybody in fact and he
went down to how many police cars they
brought how many fire engines are bought
and he professionalized the police
department and the fire department two
to two departments that are essential
obviously in any town and he just he was
a bug for not spending more than he had
to spend but spend what was necessary
for a professional operation it appears
that he had a profound impact on your
life you were born in 1927 this was two
years before the stock market crash and
the Great Depression in 1930 at the
beginning of the Great Depression he
took you in the family to Teaneck New
Jersey by the way read about this in
this book because it's the building of a
great man and a system to build a great
system and he came as the manager of
that town I'm going to read a quote of
your father that relates to what you're
saying government is a science and I'm
happy that the officials in the people
of this community agree that the man who
is the manager should be thoroughly
trained in the science of government and
in that in that part of the book you
also refer to that it was a solidly
middle-class town and you referred to
his good education his basic good solid
education and in the book you talk about
your good solid education you talk about
the importance of family and the science
of government the idea of that good
management and you refer to its outcomes
that there was no crime in Teaneck New
Jersey The Saturday Evening Post wrote
in our
that's entitled there is no crime in
Teaneck New Jersey because it was
well-managed because there was a middle
class because there's good education I'm
interested in what you think is
happening to infrastructure education
family middle class and government
management and you expressed worries
about the United States as position in
the world do you think these things are
related what are your hello all these
things you say very familiar but I grew
up precisely at the time when I graduate
from high school or college World War
two was over the United States at one
the war in our opinion it rules the
world it developed presumably a
multicultural multi lateral system of
governance and mutual growth it all
seemed very successful we kind of forget
that we had two miserable wars in
Vietnam and then in Iraq but by and
large I grew up in a world to where you
know I moved in the United States
Treasury I felt the kingpin those
Treasuries around the world you work
well I wasn't the US Treasury was yes
the Australia and the Federal Reserve
that's different now we're learning in a
world where we're still top dog maybe
with the top dog isn't so readily
recognized by others as it was and we
obviously have the rise of China as a
clear competitive for world influence
and how that all works out we'll see but
it's it's not the comfortable world of
assume leadership that I grew up with
and that's what I struggled with in the
Treasury and later in the Federal
Reserve there are other forces the rest
of the world is growing some of them
more rapidly than we when I was in
Federal Reserve Japan was the big
question as to the arrival of the United
States and go
properly has a very good success
economically we kind of forget about
that now as things changed now it's
China but we have to learn in the world
in which we needed supplies America is
not taking for granted anyone and I'm
afraid that's been speeded up but what's
been happening in Washington and the
countries in the last four or five years
House help weary obviously that this
divided divisive miss and the Congress
divisive nough sin the country it's made
it impossible to take very coherent
consistent approaches towards domestic
problems but particularly toward foreign
policy and that sense again that we are
the natural leader we have certain
allies that seem permanent ten or
fifteen years ago don't seem so feminine
anymore it's a tougher situation that we
have to accommodate tool that makes some
emphasis on effective government well
the more important in my mind who is
going to appreciate the United States as
a leader if we don't seem to be able to
manage our own affairs at home you keep
referring to management of the
government and your father was the
manager and you've been around the
management of all governments around the
world
you've also explained that the
discouragement of government workers to
be professional managers could you
embellish on that point I know this is
maybe probably your greatest mission is
to have a beneficial impact on that you
know there are two million employees and
federal employees not counting the army
the Air Force is over two million
civilian employees which is exactly the
same amount we had back in the Kennedy
administration which is 80 years ago yes
and you asked how is it government
operating same number of people
that there's an awful lot of outsourcing
out contracting that's the kohu Defense
Department itself out sources 300
billion a year or more who's minding the
store and I'm not sure we're well enough
equipped for those two million people I
headed a through ition on the civil
service when I left the Federal Reserve
which was in 1987 and there was a big
Commission we had ex vice presidents we
had a cabinet offices we had congressmen
we had a lot of people who issued a good
report what impact did it have very
little about how you needed to develop a
more effective civil service make it
easier to hire and make it easier to
fire get the right leadership in there
which some departments have and some do
not have five years later he headed
another Commission much smaller
Commission with another good report but
what impact does it have not enough one
of the observations it's often struck me
this is a feeling by you know many
businessmen the government is not
efficient doesn't do things right it's
filtered a lot of time service and I'm
very helpful which obviously there are
isolated places where all those things
are true but by and large I have been
struck by the number of businessmen
who've been called in the government for
a secretary or something rather than the
secretary in the White House whoever who
after two or three years in government
say I didn't realize there were so many
people in the government that knew what
they were doing and could do it
effectively and it's one of the biggest
experiences I take away from my years in
government that it's much more effective
potentially with a bit of staffing than
I thought but that's a hard hard lesson
to sell generally and it's not always
true we have to improve the damn thing
and that's what I'm after at at this
point in your life the thing that you
have devoted the most to is the proper
nationalisation education of of
government managers you've created the
volcker alliance in which you've devoted
you most of your net worth - yeah in
order to foster the proper development
of government workers in that way you've
spoken to me in the past about how
they're not respected and also how it's
difficult at universities and various
places to get them to be attracted in
there because they're not given a good
career path they're not given good
training and they're not given much
respect and that that is undermining the
effectiveness of the system what are
your thoughts about that thank you
you've preached my sermon well I been
concerned about the strength of the
civil service you know people who want
to go into civil service often can be
selected and maybe in a school of public
administration say okay you got a job
it's February but we can't have you and
can't pay you until the new fiscal year
which is six months away so these people
can't sit around with no pay or they
think for six months if they go got a
job on Wall Street or someplace instead
but that's a typical of the kind of
thing that needs to be repaired but what
concerned me is yeah titude stored
government itself and the difficulties
getting in attracting and keeping the
best people paralleled by the glowing
lack of interest as I see it in
universities 50 years ago hundred years
ago schools has departments or schools
of Public Administration Public
Administration is a bad word now people
associate public administration with a
bunch of time servers sitting in some
government office producing nothing
useful the administration people don't
think that when you say business
administration but they think it went
yeah it's a government administration
but we have a problem and these schools
many
them have lost sight of how to teach
what are they teaching what should the
curriculum be how do we train people to
oversee all that outsourcing hundreds of
billions of dollars being outsourced
who's minding the store are people
equipped to do that
have we taught them the right thing have
we taught him how to manager we taught
talk them out of debate issues is a
right a good memorandum how to deal with
other people other departments and so on
this little vocal Alliance is trying to
get a kind of marriage new marriage
between universities and the government
state and local government as well as
federal government to see whether we can
develop a stronger sense of interest in
efficiency last time this is true in the
United States was before World War one
when there was a great movement for
improving government and the Civil
Service came into effect and up through
the Depression years there's a lot of
pressure a lot of done to improve
government organization but a lot of
people wanted to go into government now
we are what he is later
we've lost much of that so would you say
a principle of yours is that in order to
have effective government you have to
have effective civil servants will you
call them civil servants whatever you
call them you had two people running I'm
with Alexander Hamilton the true test of
government is the ability to get
something done efficiently and we lapse
in that respect you've been in contact
with economics in every country every
major country is that a distinguishing
characteristic of those that are
successful and those that are not you
have to have a great feeling commitment
to whatever you're doing whether it's
economists a civil servant and they
still exist you know there's still a lot
of people in government had a great
sense of commitment to doing what's
going on and
you know look at this present change in
government I think there's something
like 700 maybe more potential
presidential appointments in the new
government all the secretaries and the
secretaries assistant secretaries judges
so forth and so on about a third of
those offices are filled now nobody's
paying attention now who's running those
departments well the civil servants are
left there they've been good for maybe
not but leaderless basically that isn't
the way to run a gun that's just one
example of the difficulties were having
these days looking around the rule the
world what are the principles of great
government well obviously you need a
strong leader at the top that helps
quite a lot but what we are running into
is the life of democracies democracies
really able to do the kind of thing I'm
talking about or do they eventually as
Plato said end up with something tock
recei and you can't really maintain a
democracy over a period of years but you
have you know countries like France and
Germany had a very discipline very
prestigious civil service so did the UK
that's deteriorated a lot in recent
years because it's considered too
elitist to to law removed from the
public Ashley and I guess this is a
great trick how can you get the
expertise that you need and the
leadership that you need and still
respect the popular desire then the vote
in the end and the politicians are going
to decide the direction in which to go
you refer to Plato's cycle on the ripple
in the Republic the idea of course that
democracies are threatened describe that
and describe how you feel that that
pertains to today's situations well I
think you look at the United States that
were very familiar with you have a very
divisive new administration you have the
kind of gridlock that we saw in the
Obama administration I was friendly with
mr. Obama I was disappointed he couldn't
get more done but but who you had a
situation where the Congress in effect
said the Senate said whatever mr. bomb
Obama is for were against and they
maintained that position for three years
really and that the government suffer
from that yes
did it have a really well-designed
efficient health care system for the
uninsured was tried very hard but it was
very difficult to develop it and
maintain it and you see symptoms of that
sort all over the place now inability to
read some reasonable consensus on how to
administer certain programs or how in
the first place to get agreement and
what the program will be and it's done
of phenomenon just for the United States
unfortunately it's obviously in Eastern
Europe Latin America's a hardship case
almost from top to bottom but even
within the established democratic
countries in the euro zone having some
trouble and maintaining the progress
that we made internationally the
developing set of international rules
and developments that suit everybody and
the feeling that they don't suit
everybody and they're too many people
have been left out I think that's that's
a real problem that mr. Trump has
touched upon
and kind of the real base for his
support but whether we're handling in
the right way is my mind pretty doubtful
at the moment you had probably the
greatest economic challenge and you were
both also the greatest most powerful man
in the in the country in the world
actually in terms of your control of a
monetary policy so 14.8% inflation is
where we hit in March of 1980 and as a
result of that you tighten monetary
policy I remember it very well
you said an m1 target of 5.5 percent and
as a result of that interest rates went
up to 20% more than ever expected and
when you when you tighten monetary
policy like that it drove the
unemployment rate up to 10% and it
caused the worst downturn in that period
of time since the Great Depression and
you held tight in that there were
protests there was anger and you held
tight in that and you followed it
through and as a result of that you
broke the back of inflation and in 1983
that inflation rate went down to 3%
inflation at that time and we began a
decade of prosperity of strong growth
with low inflation now you had to have a
vision of what it was like yet to fight
through that vision despite all the
opposition that's an example of
leadership under under people now look
back and they say that was a great
accomplishment but at that time that
must have been very difficult can you
describe this and then also tell us more
about what you've seen to be the
qualities of great leadership that
you've seen in others as well well this
all happened the fighting inflation
inflation itself 15 years
roughly and people today you know know
people my age are all dying and even
middle aged people were children then
and they may not remember the atmosphere
as was experienced the inflation rate is
going up for more than a decade they
were kind of feeble efforts to deal with
it during the Ford administration they
handed out putting slip inflation now
but had no had more buttons than policy
then there was always this conflict it's
always exist don't tighten monetary
policy too far you'll get some
unemployment so we want a decade that
way and we've got more inflation and
more unemployment and when I took over
the Federal Reserve at the end of
Carter's administration President Carter
was totally frustrated because he seemed
to be unable to take any initiative
anyway because all this inflation was
backed by Iran and he couldn't do
anything in the budget couldn't do
anything on anything all these things he
would have liked that it seemed to be
stalled by this fear of inflation and it
was very real at that time and so he
asked me to become chairman of the
Federal Reserve well it was obvious that
existing policies weren't working and
actually I was in the Federal Reserve
before that voting against some of those
policies but I decided we had the change
in approach and we've got to stop
worrying about increasing unemployment
at any time we've got to deal with this
inflation though it's going to get worse
and worse because it was accelerating
when they got close to fifteen percent
annual rate and that we pussy-footed
much longer was going to be 20% and
people were really fearful about the
stability of the country so we did
tighten it took a long while actually
for the unemployment ready to go up was
very stubborn and the inflation rate was
very stubborn and we made one or two
false moves so we had to take back and
look a little longer than we thought but
I saw no other way to approach this
other than kind of a bulldog in biting
at it
straight out and I got plenty of worried
in 82 when we did begin getting
unemployment the damn inflation rate
wasn't coming down and the money supply
wasn't coming down the way we wanted but
I felt we were stuck we we couldn't back
off all the effort we were making would
be for naught fortunately by the summer
of 82 things when he spiked him down
relation rate became coming down we had
a recession but by the end of the year
looked like the recession could be over
or at least stopped getting worse and it
ended pretty quickly but it took that
last year of sticking with it that I
think was necessary to do the job now
you talk about how unpopular was the
farmers had tractors outside the Federal
Reserve we had community groups we had
one congressman spent every day for two
years asking for my impeachment but my
sense was the country as a whole
understood that inflation was getting in
spite of throat and they were willing to
sit back and not be too aggressive
because they thought I was attacking a
problem that needed to be attacked and I
had more support I think I know I did a
good measure that was when my
reemployment came on at the end of this
process was first nominated it was
unanimous nominated four years later it
was not unanimous as a Democrat voting
against me eight Republicans they were
left-wing Democrats eight Lightning
Republicans in 84 votes with me and I
think that was a fair representation
that people things were getting better
than but people tolerated what it took
to deal with the inflation problem and I
don't think there was any other answers
I can saw myself it was a tough time but
you have any other answer there with you
what you know I remember you going
through it every single day I was
wondering what Paul Volcker was thinking
since you said that you said the m1
target of five and a half percent and I
did the calculations of velocity and I
thought oh my god is that really going
to be happening because you you know you
have a 14 percent inflation that means
the interest rates have got to go up it
was in so it was it was a time people
don't have any understanding of that how
challenging that time was they we think
of 2008 but the 1982 the unemployment
rate rising to 10% the rate at which the
economy plunged all of those conditions
were worse than a 1982 not 2008 so it's
a it was a more dramatic time even in
terms of volatility of interest rates
where people forget about going back on
his computer 2008 we had a bankrupt
Latin America the bank said head over
heels and lending the Latin America they
had one and a half to two times their
capital not just big American banks but
big international banks hopes were
invested in Latin America one day Mexico
said we can't pay anymore August 1982
and what happens
well we hook him by cooking with the
help of the IMF which is very important
we stalled stalled for time and he's
like oh this isn't that very dramatic
we got the bank's because they was in
their own interest to continue lending
enough to pay interest anyway we forced
constructive reforms we thought on
Mexico Brazil Argentina a lot of that's
been lost since but that was with the
help of the IMS and it held together we
didn't have a banking collapse wasn't
subprime or
there was subprime subprime
latin-american bar it was a good example
of how you could roll things forward
from 1982 until 1991 when they had the
brady thought is correct and things have
capital had been restored some of the
debts had been lowered and he could
finish it off with the so-called lady
brady plan this you have known most
world leaders for most of the last 50 60
70 years tell me what are your
principles about what makes a great
world leader or a great leader in
general sometimes you get close to them
they don't seem so great but you know
when you look around that world leaders
in recent years
when you begin thinking of I think mrs.
Merkel did a pretty good job in Europe
and Germany we had dinner with Lee Kuan
Yew you and I remember Lee Kuan Yew was
the next name I was going to mention and
the third name I was gonna mention is I
don't know how much you went into xuanji
just I mean he's been a hero of mine I
didn't know him first well he was a hero
of mine this this is in 1990s when I was
to China quite a lot I don't go to China
very little now and I don't know the Lee
is now but I know the leaders in the 90s
when they seem to be a blossoming
capitalist economy or to exaggerate a
bit with hopes for an open democratic
society doesn't look that way quite now
but back when dung and xuanji were where
they look very promising and they come
to us for advice they don't come for
advice anymore you might come to us and
tell us what the Tobin well they seem to
be doing pretty good that's right that's
right they say we don't have to follow
you anymore but Lin Kuan Yew of course
is a special case Hughes what are those
qualities well he knew what he wanted to
get done and he did it and it is small
relative Enclave and he did a lot of
things that we
cut it about in terms of democracy he
was little too easy to put people in
jail and to quiet down opposition and
worry about what the newspaper said
about him and so forth but he had a
drive to develop Singapore with a very
strong civil service very effective grew
up free government as near as I could
say and he pulled it off and he
maintained a very strong position then
Singapore is economically I don't know
where ranks in the world by per capita
income but its way up there we I so your
principles if I get it correctly your
principles would be a great leader has
an accurate vision of where to go a
great leader has will fight the
opposition in pursuit of that and
deliver a great leader has a deep caring
for the people that they're leading a
great leader also seems to be leading
with a an effective management of civil
service in government or a effective
bureaucracy to carry those things
through those the principles well I
think we have to add a principle the one
you've had you've got to have a respect
for the people I don't know whether you
included that you know some of the
qualities you mention either apply to
Adolf Hitler but we don't want an eight
out of Italy we've got somebody that's
got some democratic instincts and
recognizes that he's only there
temporarily and that he is wants to lead
the country effectively but peaceably
and without dictatorial demands so it's
a nice balance to be charged and it may
be less efficient when you have to deal
with public opinion and differing points
of view but it's obviously essential of
democracies kundo
kind of last we legitimately worried
about the
our casino my mother who was quite a
character herself I recall vaguely
whining to her when I was probably a
young man in government Vietnam war or
something rioting history to race up on
our we were threatened that the country
was threatened to survive all these
tensions said Sonny Boy Sheena called me
Sonny Boy she said we're 200 years a
democracy we've been a longer democracy
everybody else in the world we've gotten
over worse than this before go get back
to work and do something and I take a
little comfort in that thought that we
can straighten ourselves out after this
little turmoil that's a little turmoil
what do you see the United States is
future China's future over the next 10
years let's say well you know I
sometimes sounds terrible but I respond
more favorably to what the president of
China is saying than the President of
the United States President China at
least says that he's looking forward to
harmonious relationship over time and
that early he's looking for the world
being divided up through different
spheres of influence and the china will
take care of the Asian sphere but
looking for peaceable outcomes where
we're all threats and and demands so
it's different story being told now
there's some justice of course in what
Trump is doing it is true during our
period of leadership we tended to
overlook in our own country some of the
problems that world leadership implied
in terms of willing to accept a lot of
imports in particular and we began
getting overwhelmed with imports and
it's only part of the sections didn't
bother Wall Street doesn't bother
California but a bar that all those
small manufacturers are not so small
manufacturers that
losing Ellen's and it's true we do have
a big current account deficit it's not
all China but in China don't go has a
big surplus said it had worldwide so we
ran up the analyzing this all correctly
but there's no doubt we've had some
unevenness and repercussions in the
United States which present a real
political problem and we've got to
resolve it that political problem is the
polarity that political problem is the
wealth gap described the political
problem well to reach some agreement
about what an appropriate influx under
what conditions immigrants are we've
recent years taking a lot of immigrants
maybe we don't want so many but what
should the rules be both in terms of our
economic needs but in terms of all moral
needs when people are being oppressed in
different ways and how can we develop an
economy that's more balanced between the
great middle part of the country and the
two coastal areas where a lot of the
vigor seems to exist and that's a big
challenge it's not going to be healed
overnight what are we gonna do about the
big issues of from my point of view
climate change we don't seem to be able
to reach and work with other countries
effectively in that area which may kill
the whole next generation if we don't
worry about us so a lot of issues that
somehow I've been polarized to the
extent who haven't very difficulty in
achieving the consensus that we need
Paul what would you like your legacy to
be oh god my legacy I'd like to see my
legacy a more effective government in
general I haven't got any control over
the high politics or any influence but I
would like to see a general acceptance
of the need for an efficient public
service ethic and see people attracted
toward public service because they can
take satisfaction that they're doing
something
concrete for the country and the people
generally and it can certainly test
their own acumen and intelligence and
energy to do that kind of thing you know
my father I'm sure that rest of about
spending so much time in government but
I'm sure that in the end he found that
as satisfying career and didn't make a
lot of money he made enough to live on
simply enough I would like to see that
kind of spirit permeate a wider
population and it once did there's no
doubt about it when I grew up when I got
out of college and I got out of graduate
school going in the government was a
popular thing to do now people scratch
their head and say why would you ever
want to do that and that's not a very
healthy sign which goes along with the
20 percent confidence in government to
do things right back when Kennedy came
and it was overdone with all the spirit
that he had and I was a young man and
full of Kennedy glamour respect for the
u.s. that same question do you trust
your government could up 60 or 70
percent said yes so that's a healthy we
should be skeptical I want 30% to be
skeptical and what more than 30% to be
skeptical these chemicals is one thing
but being anti-government is another
thing that we've parrot we don't dismiss
it what does the Volcker Alliance do we
are young and small organizations but
we're trying to get some cohesiveness is
what we perceived many people perceive
about the needs of government for
effective administration and effective
people and get better connection between
the needs of the government and the
universities with schools the public
administration of public policy that can
feed this potential demand more
effectively than it's been done recently
the recruitment between the federal
government and young people in between
the universe
he's so lacks it's almost disappeared
then that's not right these universities
have to review what they're doing to see
how they can really educate effectively
and the government has to cooperate with
them and then see what kind of people
they need and how they need to be
trained how they can be employed with a
minimum of red tape and and delays and
be given satisfying jobs because there's
no doubt that a lot of challenges of
government a lot of opportunities
analyzed for challenging jobs
how would you hope that the government
would work with the volca or Alliance to
visualize that goal what parts of well
you answer what you ask a sensitive
question where were examining precisely
that issue there are people in the OMB
Office of Management and Budget the
management part of that has been very
weak but it still exists it's been there
I guess since the Truman administration
that should be a central focus for
government management with a few experts
and interested people they now are
taking an initiative to do precisely
what I'm talking about so we had us
seven or eight questions we asked all 50
states with the help of summon
universities how are you doing in
budgeting how are you doing are you cut
funds to reserve for emergencies how's
your pension system and three or four
other questions we published a nice
shiny book all the states were ranked
didn't rank them in order but we said
you're doing a good job their job
impossible job let's attract a lot of
attention because it's competition
between the states so people oh my god
here we got a report for the Valco
alliance it says we don't have good
budgetary arrangements so some of them
have actually changed their budgeting
procedures that's a good example of an
impact of the Volcker Alliance but yeah
and it'll put the grades on those
actually for everybody to see change his
behavior you know everybody talks about
nobody's doing anything about it that I
can see anyway over you know such
obvious infrastructure projects is due
to new rail tunnels under the Hudson
we're sitting here with leaking tunnels
totally dependent upon these two very
fragile existing pieces of
infrastructure that would built more
than 100 years ago what are we wasting
time on a few blocks of the second
Avenue subway why are we wasting a lot
of time with some elaborate way of
bringing two or three Long Island trains
in the Grand Central Station when big
obvious needs are going undone so I'm
trying to make a little project to bring
out some of those problems and does it
take the federal government leadership
to somehow bring people together to see
which of the most urgent of these
infrastructure problems and to what
extent should the federal government
that inevitably we gets involved be
doing the financing and checking its
viability working with the states and
cities and it's just not being done now
no it should be done in the States are
all being squeezed financially which
makes it all more difficult how can
others help the your you achieve your
legacy and the volcker alliance they can
look it up look it up on their iPhone I
guess they can see but we we do need
some money and we are at a point where
you know we've got some money to
function this year next year but we're
gonna continue after that we're going to
need some influx of real money we're a
very small organization but it's
interesting what you can do with a small
organization but we do have to get and
we're gonna spend this year making
another try demanding more cooperation
from the universities themselves because
they potentially have more resources and
we have the public administration public
management they put a lot of money in
the business management
not putting money in the public
management economics it was a
prestigious hesitate to call it a
science but it's got great prestige or
did until it missed the 2008 crisis
pretty completely economists have lost a
lot of prestige I thinking in recent
years and rightfully so but the amount
of money that's been poured into
economic research has compared the
amount of money poured into research and
public administration is astonishing
this just hasn't got the same respect my
old University of Princeton once got a
huge donation for public management
training for public service where's the
money too close to the Economics
Department and to oversimplify when I
went to Princeton the question of
Princeton was a professor of Public
Administration I tell people that now in
the Economics Department
they don't believe it that Woodrow
Wilson was the father of public
administration President of Princeton
one of the things he did not touch upon
but which I think they were a big
problem is the amount of corruption in
the world fiduciary responsibilities
seems to vanish from the lexer doesn't
vanish from their statements the nice
statements of ethics that they print but
when I get sounded a trading desk or
good sounds Oh making a deal with
Malaysian with the big payoff you wonder
whether the ethical standards ever get
down to the people doing the work and
the enormous number of conflicts of
interests that have developed in banks
and elsewhere and in finance I did a
study of what make countries succeed and
fail with a ten year time horizon looked
at different indicators and there's a
negative 52 percent correlation in other
words a very strong negative
correlation between the level of
corruption and the level of relative
growth you recently received a lot of
attention for making the statement that
related to government that it's a hell
of a mess all around and I think you
were talking more broadly but clarify
what you mean by that with her faint
news you don't know what to believe what
not to believe you got presidents that
don't seem to mind either personal
behavior or making outrageous statements
true or not you have a Congress that's
been unable to function effectively now
maybe that hopefully maybe that'll
change a little bit but we'll wait and
see you after this past election but we
have not been on a constructive track oh
yeah I think that's fair to say we were
M through a massive tax bill whatever
you think about that tax bill shouldn't
be rammed through the Congress without
any debates that midnight on December
31st or whatever was done with almost
nobody in the Congress having a very
good idea what was in the bill what do
you like what was in or not it's not it
wasn't subject to the right kind of
debate that we should have had but that
seems to be true and other areas as well
no I just refer you to the morning press
if you want to know a description of how
effective government is these days so a
lot of people have claimed that we've
always had challenges in government and
we've been through these things
including my mother well and my lifetime
this I think there was a general after
world war two again when we were king of
the crop it was a broad consensus about
the broad outlines of foreign policy and
there was a willingness of both
Republican and Democratic presidents to
kind of lead what NATO leads the World
Trade Organization lead the whole effort
to reduce
Terrace that all went hand in hand a lot
of debates about it but the basic or the
policy was generally accepted and that's
changed and we're not always going to
have happy harmony about what policy
should be but you got to do a little
better than we've been doing recently
and go back to what I think I said some
time ago of all the presidential
appointments for less than half
anybody's even been nominated much less
appointed the quality of the people
appointed through cabinet offices the
sub cabinet office I think by any
estimation is not up to scratch that
didn't say there are not good and
effective appointments but when you see
lobbyists for polluting companies named
head of the agency for anti-pollution
you wonder by the coherent nature of the
appointment and this happening too often
that State Department ripped apart maybe
it should be ripped apart but it ought
to be done in a constructive way we
haven't got haven't had an ambassador in
Saudi Arabia we have all these fathers
of Saudi Arabia I mean even got an
ambassador there until now why not I
mean too much policy seems to be out of
the back pocket today and God knows what
happens tomorrow look for no government
man like me it doesn't look very good
hence my comment let's hope it gets
better
well thank you Paul for spending this
time and also conveying some of your
principles and also some of what you're
hoping will be achieved over the next
few years to make up your legacy i'm i
hope that we can help you achieve know
thank you for coming I appreciate the
opportunity to rant and rave a little
bit because I think the country needs a
little ranting and raising and you do
that so well